the top business stories live from the
Sky News City Studio
calls for supermarkets to be held to
account as an investigation finds bigger
profit margins of cost drivers an extra
six pence per liter at the pump
more than 12 billion pounds right from
the stock market value of AstraZeneca as
results of a cancer drug trial
disappoint investors
and pressure on Britain's Bank across on
interest rate hikes to Savers I'll be
speaking with the chair of the treasury
Select Committee
thank you
good afternoon this is business live
with Ian King the chancellor has
promised to make it a legal requirement
for companies to publish their petrol
and diesel prices to help drive down
prices it comes after an investigation
by the competition of markets Authority
which found that drivers have been
paying an extra six pence per liter
because retailers have pushed up their
profit margins the investigation was
launched last July as fuel prices hit
record highs in the wake of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
or data from RAC fuel watch suggested
unleaded petrol prices peaked at around
191 Pence per liter last July and have
now fallen back to around 143 Pence per
liter for diesel the peak was even
higher hitting 199 Pence per liter it
now costs around 145 Pence per liter
well earlier on today I spoke with the
chief executive of the competition and
markets Authority about the measures
they're recommending
for both petrol and Diesel we've seen
that the margins for retailers have
increased over recent years and what
we're seeing is that at the end of the
day that motorists are not getting the
best deal possible most risks are paying
more than they would be paying if
margins had remained at historic levels
we think we need to inject a real dose
of extra competition into this Market
that needs to happen quickly so we've
put forward two key recommendations to
government today to take forward an open
data field finder scheme that will make
it much easier for motorists to find the
best deal from their phone from their
car without having to drive around from
from Station to Station and at the same
time we think the market needs to remain
subject to ongoing scrutiny and we're
recommending the introduction of a new
fuel monitoring scheme to set that up so
what we've seen is that Asda in
particular historically has been the
cheapest of the supermarkets back in
2022 they took a decision to increase
their internal margin targets actually
trouble their margin targets we saw a
similar move by Morrisons to double
their targets now in a market where
competition is working well you'd expect
other retailers of the supermarket other
fuel retailers to respond competitively
to seek to win market share we haven't
seen that happen at all we've seen a
complete absence of any kind of
competitive reaction instead the
retailers as whole have tended to track
the price movements and that's resulted
in overall increase in margins at the
expense of the motorist
is it possible to look at supermarket
fuel pricing in isolation given how a
lot of the multiples Link in store
discounts to what people pay the pumps
yeah so we have been looking very
specifically here as you say through our
12-month Market study of what's
happening in the road fuel Market that's
enabled us really to drill down and get
to the bottom of the decisions that
individual retailers have been taking
that's very separate from the review
that we're doing at the moment looking
at grocery prices more broadly we'll be
reporting back on that in a few weeks
time now the liberal Democrats in
response to your reporters said they
want Supermarket Executives hauled into
Downing Street and stripped of their
bonuses what do you make of that
well I think what we're really focusing
on is making sure that we can work with
the government now to improve
competition in this market we think
there's a real opportunity to do that to
make sure motorists can get the best
information possible to be able to make
the right choices and to make sure that
as a result of that there's greater
competitive pressure on these retailers
that they have to often offer most risks
the best deal possible in an Ideal World
how quickly would this be implemented
I think it's really important this is
implemented as quickly as possible we
can see see the detriment to most risks
at the moment so we will be absolutely
working with government to take this
forward as quickly as they're able to
well the CMA said Asda and Morrisons
made a conscious decision last year to
raise their profit margins as there was
also fined sixty thousand pounds for
failing to provide information when it
was requested well Asda has responded
this afternoon by saying despite record
inflation we have carefully managed our
business to ensure Asda was the cheapest
traditional Supermarket for both
groceries and fuel throughout the period
reviewed by the CMA and this position is
unchanged meanwhile Morrisons has said
the calculation of margin on fuel does
not include the cost of running a fuel
business such as energy rents and
payroll which have substantially
increased through the cost of living
crisis while volumes have declined since
covid
some other business news stories for you
now and shares of AstraZeneca have
fallen by more than seven percent today
wiping more than Twelve and a half
billion pounds from the drugs of giant
stock market value as trial results for
a new lung cancer treatment proved
disappointing AZ said that the treatment
dato DxD had demonstrated a significant
Improvement in progression-free survival
in patients with non-small cell lung
cancer compared with the current
standard of care chemotherapy but
investors took flight at az's failure to
discuss the test results as clinically
meaningful and use that some patients
treated during the trial had died more
than one million people worldwide are
diagnosed with Advanced non-small cell
lung cancer annually
the UK's manufacturing set to contracted
last month for the 11th consecutive
month according to survey data published
this morning s p Global cips UK
manufacturing purchasing managers index
in which anything above 50 represents
growth and anything below that a
contraction came in at 46.5 for June
that was down from 47.1 in May and was
the weakest reading for the sector this
year Well s p Global said the figures
reflected lackluster demand in both
domestic and overseas markets with
levels of output new orders and
employment all suffering further
declines
Diagnostics company your Gene Health has
agreed to an 18 million pound takeover
by its larger rival Nova sites group
your Gene which is based in Manchester
was founded 10 years ago and provides
Technologies and services to enable
genomic medicine these include
non-invasive prenatal tests and
screening products in reproductive
health and precision medicine used to
test for Cystic Fibrosis well the pair
said today that their combination would
create a more scaled Diversified
operator in the diagnostic sector
and excitement around generative
artificial intelligence has started to
have an impact on mergers and
Acquisitions activity among corporates
last week saw nearly two billion dollars
worth of done deals done with the data
storage and management firm databricks
paying 1.3 billion dollars for the
generative AI startup Mosaic ML and
Thompson Reuters paying 650 million
dollars for the legal AI specialist case
text but could they be wasting their
money well joining me now to talk about
this is Fernando Luchini he's data
science and machine learning lead at
Accenture uh Fernanda good to see you
this morning I mean it's interesting to
see some like this being spent but are
these deals going to pay for themselves
in the long run do you think well thank
you for having me first thanks a lot
it's a very interesting time it's some
of these breakthroughs I think we're
still all trying to understand what they
mean we're still trying to apply them to
the real world we've got this balance of
interesting and useful is it really
interesting is it really useful
um I I don't think it's uh it's anything
but interesting to see these sums being
used and how they will use them next I
think will be even more interesting is
there an element of fomo fear of missing
out here going on I think so and it's
even worse I think for chief Executives
and companies who feel the further I
think there's the most exaggerated
firmware I think in the history of
Technology thinking do I do something do
I not do something but I do think it's
captured the world's imagination and I
think it's also captured the exact it
really has I mean it does feel like an
inflection point here all this talk
about genitive AI oh absolutely and we
have to remind ourselves that maybe six
months ago very few of us were talking
about this that are as AI Geeks and now
100 million people are hands on keyboard
putting queries into these and getting
things out of it so it's not just a fomo
it's a real people are really using it
but what's interesting though is that
generative AI at the moment it seems
very good at language based on Creative
tasks it doesn't really feel that great
on tasks such as data management well
it's superpowers that it understands
language and it is effectively like an
enormous dictionary something that
understands language but it has no you
know critical thinking it's some common
common understanding through large
amounts of text so yes it's naturally
very good at language but what extent do
you think businesses would be better off
in some cases in trying to develop their
own AI platform specific to their own
industry it's a trend that hasn't really
sorted itself so on one hand we have
these enormous galactic-sized models and
then we have a quite a lot of smaller
size open source that we can all use
freely and I think we haven't quite
figured out where we're going with this
do we want the really enormous language
that knows language inside out or do we
need a very industry specific we can put
beds but I don't think it's salted salt
just yet which Industries do you think
are being most transformed right now by
generative AI it should be those that
are very very deep in text so you've
mentioned emerges and Acquisitions
emergency accesses requires a lot of
understanding of text so maybe that's a
good one the legal profession is full of
text Pharmaceuticals are full of text
and knowledge so very knowledge heavy
should be able to use this to their
advantage what about Banking and finance
I mean that's a sector that an awful lot
of people are talking about in this
regard more absolutely they will come
close second second third I think we'll
all be impacted since it is at the core
of it isn't standing of language and we
all use language all the time so but it
is a co-pilot people use that term it is
a little helper that was going to help
us manage our language better a business
is doing enough to apply AI to their to
what their activities right now I mean
it doesn't feel as though it's
completely widespread it's very it's
very sort of uneven Bob thankfully I
think the Gen AI revolution has told the
rest of the rest of the world that they
should use AI more broadly we shouldn't
confuse AI is not equal to sorry gen AI
is not equal to AI it's not equal to
data it's not equal to everything so I
think it's time to highlight what have
we not done in Ai and why maybe we ask
ourselves a question of why
said well what's your theory tell me
Well AI is still a science it's not hard
to do it's still quite scientific it
still applies to certain areas of
problems not all of them and Gene AI of
course all of us can put our fingers to
the keyword as long as we've got fingers
keyboard we qualify to use gen AI today
which work for maybe a simulation system
for AI would have been requiring much
more expertise all right Fernanda we
have to leave it I'm afraid good to talk
to you today thank you
still to come here on in building
business live the treasury committee
calls on banks to ensure they're passing
on interest rate Rises to Savers I'll be
speaking with the chair of the committee
Harriet Baldwin
[Music]
I'm Dan weised and I'm Sky News is west
of England correspondent
foreign
[Music]
to bustling cities we spend every day
reporting from across the region
the pound has rallied moderation
interest rates peaking up at six percent
the highest for 14 years will that be
the peak will it be a little bit lower
prices it's closer to a potential crash
so many words so many meanings but what
do they mean for you and your finances
stay up to date on Sky News
I'm Stuart Ramsey and on Sky's Chief
correspondent well there's a real sense
now that people are beginning to expect
that this whole airlift is coming to an
end and they're really really desperate
snatch words going in grabbing people
and putting into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover or you've
done it
okay so that's like a wall That's the
war yes
we help you understand the world with us
for the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
is really sending a clear message that
Venezuela is eager for change
we've been crossed
we'll take you to the heart of stories
that shape our world
convinced the United States will become
hooked well they were right
normal six thousand has just come down I
think it was a monsters just landed in
between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in Iraq and
Syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
so hot
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Fly Emirates fly better
[Music]
well Equity markets in Continental
Europe looked to have made a good start
to the second half of the year but
they've given up those gains as a
session has gone on there you go and the
the Ibex in Madrid and the mibin Milan
in positive territory at the end of the
session talking points in Europe today
included generali shares of Italy's
biggest insurer have closed by more than
three percent higher in Milan after the
wealthy Del Vecchio family's investment
vehicle was permitted by Regulators to
take a 10 stake we're here in London the
ftse 100 is off to a losing start for
the second half of the Year gains for
the miners have been balanced by losses
in the health care sector and in
particular in AstraZeneca I mentioned
that big share price reverse that has
wiped nearly 48 points from the index on
its own AstraZeneca off-8 procession
percent on the day the leading Blue Chip
Gainer was last anglo-american up by
nearly four and a half percent that's
after De Beers in which it owns an 85
stake struck a new 10-year Diamond
production agreement with the Botswana
government well in the United States
stocks have been trading largely to the
upside this afternoon in a shortened
session ahead of tomorrow's Fourth of
July holiday among talking points on
Wall Street this afternoon is Tesla who
shares open nearly seven percent higher
after it reported record second quarter
vehicle deliveries of shares of in a
nine-month high today in the same sector
another electric vehicle maker rivian is
risen by some 12 after its quarterly
sales numbers also came in ahead of
expectations uh Apple last week of
course that became the first U.S stock
to hit a valuation of three trillion
dollars as you saw it's off this
afternoon that's after the financial
times reported it's been forced to cut
production forecasts for its Vision Pro
augmented reality headset on the Foreign
Exchange Market not a lot going on
really to be honest the US dollar has
been rebounding from a tumble late last
week Sterling offered 10 to 1 against
the Greenback unchanged Against The
single currency the Euro meanwhile more
or less again unchanged against the
dollar the the oil price though there
has been a bit of activity there this
afternoon Saudi Arabia has extended its
voluntary production cuts the power of
Brent crude will currently set you back
75.99 about that's up a little over
three quarters of one percent this
afternoon with me now is Guy Ellison
he's head of listed equities at investec
wealth guy good to see you I mean
AstraZeneca you really don't see a move
in a ftse heavyweight like this every
day no and to put it into context as
you're saying Astra almost
single-handedly has has dragged the UK
Market down at the large cap end of the
index today the mid cap in the UK the
250 index trading up around half a
percent but the large cap end is flat
and just for context yeah Astra of
Friday's close was the largest company
in the UK Market just over eight percent
of our index just slightly ahead of
shell and today's fall the 12 billion
pounds or so that's been wiped off the
market cap you know that's the
equivalent of the entire market
capitalization of a company like BT or
next so yeah a very significant single
stock move extraordinary was the
sell-off overdone
now I think the sell-off is
proportionate and it's in reaction to
this phase three trial data of a new
refractory lung cancer drug that
asterisk trialling so refractory drugs
are those that you use when every other
conventional medicine has been used and
you're really looking for a last
possible chance to extend a patient's
life whilst the data did show some
success in extending patient life spans
you know as you say that the data wasn't
deemed clinically significant by
AstraZeneca this drug is important not
only does it have potential applications
in lung cancer but there are also trials
ongoing concurrently in breast cancer as
well and the market thinks the potential
sales of this drug if it gets approval
you know it could be up to 20 billion
dollars a year at their Peak that would
make it one of astrazeneca's key drug
pipelines and so what the Market's
telling you today is the probability of
this drug you know getting full approval
across a broad range of of cancers you
know now looks diminished so it looks a
proportionate response to you know what
is potentially a very significant drug
yeah no I mean this is obviously the
start of the second half markets did
well in the first half Equity markets
apart from the ftse yeah and you know
Astra today is a perfect example of why
the UK struggled over the first half of
the year so you know the UK Market just
up around two percent over the first six
months of the year comparing that to
America the s p was up 15 the NASDAQ
because of the turbocharged performance
from technology names is up 30 but
actually most European uh indices were
between 15 and 20 as well so the UK
really wants to stand out and that is
because of that really concentrated
nature of the UK Market Healthcare is 12
of our market oil and gas is another 12
neither of those sectors manage to make
any Headway over the first six months of
the year and that means it's a really
difficult job for the rest of the index
to provide any momentum all right guy
gotta leave it there good to see you
this morning this afternoon even losing
track of time with these new schedules
thanks for joining me
now the treasury committee has written
to the chief Executives of the UK's
largest banks calling on them to ensure
they're passing on interest rate Rises
to Savers the bank of England's main
policy rate hit five percent last month
but dated from the comparison website
money facts compare suggests that the
average easy access savings rate is just
2.43 banks will soon be compelled to
ensure they're providing fair value for
customers when the financial conduct
authorities consumer Duty comes into
effect at the end of the month well
Harriet Baldwin is chair of the treasury
select committee and she joins me now
Harriet Baldwin good to see you today I
mean the banks say they are increasing
savings rates particularly for some of
these fixed term savings products
well I'm sure your viewers will have
noticed that on the day the bank of
England raises rates and their raising
rates to combat inflation you'll get a
message from your mortgage company
saying your mortgage rates going up
effective immediately but the banks have
been very very slow and very grudging
about the increases in rates that
they're paying to Savers in fact we've
gone so far as to describe the rates
they pay to save us as measly and we do
recommend that people shop around and
they really try and get some of these
more competitive rates which as you say
are out there I mean banking
profitability has been crushed during
the last 15 years by near zero interest
rates I mean the banks on some levels
can't really be blamed for trying to
recoup some of that can they
well we think that they shouldn't be
recouping their profitability on the
back of their most loyal Savers so for
our constituents who are perhaps not
comfortable with internet banking
perhaps
um feel that they want to have a bank
where they've got a presence on the High
Street before they move their life
savings we think that these customers
are being particularly badly treated and
we think that where there's a loyalty
penalty you know the regulator will be
very concerned and we think it will be
hard for the banks to prove that they're
treating their customers fairly well you
say that but I mean if you strip out the
last 15 years in the exceptionally low
interest rates that we've had I mean by
historic standards net interest rate net
interest margins at the banks I don't
they're not greatly out of kilter with
where they always used to be I mean
they're just about in line with where
the banks need to make a return to their
shareholders
well they're certainly are doing that
because they've had this big windfall as
rates have been rising they haven't been
passing on that increase to their Savers
and I think part of it is that Savers
themselves need to shop around you know
we've got used over the last decade as
you say to earning nothing on our money
and uh having it just sort of sit there
if we're lucky enough to have any
savings and so it is important that
consumers shop around but I think it's
also incumbent on the banks to make sure
that they're not taking advantage of the
Loyalty of some of particularly their
elderly savings customers I mean this
consumer Duty feels a little bit
amorphous what sort of enforcement
action would you like the regulator to
be able to take if the if that duty is
not being met
that's a great question because we are
expecting that to come into Force for
existing customers at the end of July
and we've got the regulator coming in to
speak to our committee this month and
we'll be asking exactly that question
because I think one thing I hear time
and time again is that businesses like
to have that certainty ahead of time as
to how it's going to be implemented by
the regulator they don't want to be
called off guard thinking they were
doing the right thing and then
discovering retrospectively that they
weren't and so I do encourage the
regulator to show clarity as to what
kind of behavior they're expecting but
we think it's very clear that at this
point loyal Savers are not being treated
fairly now you you've just urged Savers
to try and shop around if you like but I
mean if if the government of which
you're a part was uh serious about this
then surely they'd be raising the
personal savings allowance which hasn't
increased since George Osborne
introduced it eight years ago
well I have been putting pressure on the
government absolutely it is my party in
power and they have increased uh the
national savings and investment rates
quite significantly so last week uh the
rate on premium bonds went up to four
percent that of course is tax free four
percent so it's as is one of the best
offers out there and of course it's
backed by the Safety and Security of the
government yes but what about the
personal savings allowance the amount of
interest that you're allowed to make
before you get taxed on it I mean that's
not moved since George Osborne
introduced it
think actually it's even worse than that
Ian I may be wrong on this but I think
it's actually going down isn't it next
year next tax year so
um uh one of the measures that Jeremy
hunts put in place but yeah you can
correct me if I'm wrong on that one yeah
pretty depressing
um what how quickly do you expect the
banks to respond to these letters that
you sent out today
well we know that they're in there there
where they've just finished their second
quarter haven't they so they're starting
the third quarter and I think what we're
trying to do with these letters is to
show them that we are really
scrutinizing uh their results very very
carefully they'll be releasing their
second quarter results uh towards the
end of July we will be going through
them with a fine tooth comb uh to make
sure that our constituents are not being
treated poorly as a result of their
loyalty to the High Street okay Harriet
Baldwin could leave it there appreciate
you joining me today thank you thank you
Ian that's it from me I'm back with
business live at the new time tomorrow
of 11 30 and of course this time
tomorrow as well thanks for joining me
today cheerio
[Music]